nuevo capítulo en los problemas
generados por la vacunación contra el
kobe 19 de astrazéneca el reino unido ha
anunciado 7 muertes por trombosis de
personas receptoras de la vacuna de
oxford sin embargo la agencia reguladora
de medicamentos mantiene que el riesgo
de coágulos causados por la vacuna es
muy bajo la institución asegura que ha
reportado 30 casos de coágulos entre más
de 18 millones de personas inoculadas
con la misma sustancia hasta el 24 de
marzo e insta a la población a no
rechazar el fármaco cuando les sea
ofrecido el riesgo de generar este tipo
específico de coágulo de sangre es muy
pequeño hasta el 24 de marzo incluido
habíamos recibido 22 informes de
trombosis del seno venoso cerebral y 8
informes de otras trombosis de un total
de 18,1 millones de dosis de la vacuna
contra kobe 19 de astrazéneca
administradas hasta la fecha una
posición compartida por la agencia
europea del medicamento y por la ong
quienes sostienen que los beneficios
generados por la vacuna son
mayores que los riesgos sin embargo el
miedo a los problemas de trombos por las
inyecciones de astrazéneca han llevado a
otros estados como países bajos alemania
francia o canadá a restringir el uso del
fármaco de momento londres no ha
anunciado medidas en esta dirección el
país cuenta ya con casi 5 millones de
ciudadanos completamente vacunados